hey guys I'm wheeler better known to the
Internet as the sleeping beauty proposal
guy hi I'm slippy
I'm the Sleeping Beauty proposal girl my
name is Kayla Koontz I did the artwork
for the Sleeping Beauty proposal and
this is that story this is that story
this is that story and I'm actually
sleeping beauty
so stithi and I met our freshman year of
high school she was taking a dance class
at the time and at the end of the year
all the dance classes have their final
performance and I was taking a stage
craft class at the time leave it all the
tech for it I thought he was kind of a
weird guy in the corner because he would
always wear all black it just looked
really sad I knew he was someone special
the final night of the show somebody in
the sound booth just like crank the
music and all the dancers from all the
classes just ran onstage and just
started dancing just letting loose
somehow I got dragged out of the wings
onto stage in the spotlight and somehow
I wound up dancing with stood and
naturally I was like well I got to do
something here and somebody had given
her a red rose put it in my teeth
and I started pretending like we were
tangoing which the time seemed like a
good idea
two seconds later realized there were
thorns in that rose it was such a
special and memorable moment that if you
look carefully at the video you'll see
that in that frame where we're dancing
together I actually my character has a
little rose in his mouth as an homage to
that woman yes make me tear up that part
and I thought you truly how we met and
started dating so I guess start our
story begins a few years back and a
friend of mine told me that he was
thinking about proposing to his then
girlfriend and we were just sort of
sitting there talking about how we might
do it the idea popped into my head
pretty much fully formed he's sitting
there with his significant other and
they're watching her favorite movie and
all of a sudden in a key scene like
green screen composited into the shot is
him and just a moment for her would be
like feels kind of magical is like
cognitive dissonance what are you doing
there and then it would segue to a
real-life proposal with him doing a
little fake toss and then in real life
catching it and getting down on one knee
it's like magical will be
made into her favorite movie and he
thought about it he's like you know a
set doesn't doesn't feel like it'd be
right for us and so I sort of filed that
idea away for later thinking maybe there
you know it seemed like there was
something there maybe I could get some
mileage out of it yet
fast forward few years down the road
stuffy and I were dating we started
having conversations about taking the
next step in our relationship I had of
course went to well how am I going to do
it eventually I sort of resurfaced that
idea what if I put myself into her
favorite movie and pop the question that
way and the problem was her favorite
movie is sleeping beauty which is
animated I got a copy of Sleeping Beauty
I just started scrubbing through it
because I've never seen it I got to the
end where Prince Philip comes in kneels
down
kisses Aurora like breaks the spell and
I noticed that the whole scene was
pretty static and it made me think that
maybe I didn't need to be an animator
maybe I just needed an illustrator it
had to be something that could be
seamless with Disney level animation
which is like that's as good as it gets
I just wound up going on Instagram and
using different hashtags I could kind of
discover artists who were posting with
certain styles I eventually made my way
to Kayla Koons I thought what have I
gotten myself into here this is too much
Lea sent me an email just out of the
blue you'd be available or willing to do
some artwork to help me propose to my
girlfriend we had a chat and he kind of
told me the whole vision and I was like
wow this guy this guy's got high heart
this is gonna be special if we can pull
it off Kayla Coombs is an Australian
illustrator one of her talents is she
can emulate that kind of classic Disney
style yeah it's really did not see this
coming
I had no idea and when I found my way to
her Instagram page and started scrolling
through I just remembered that be in the
moment where I thought this could
actually work so I was very excited to
just do this proposal in the comfort of
our home presented it to my friend he's
like no man have you have you never met
a woman friends and family should be
there it should be someplace beautiful
and both of our heads
to this local independent movie theater
called the Coolidge Corner theater it
just it's a it's a it's a venue that
holds a lot of significance to me and
stood the e and I have gone and seen
movies there I think this shows how
ingenious Lee is he basically had to
figure out a way not to seem so weird
that he was inviting me to a theater
full of my friends and family so he
enlisted my mom can I give you something
to send her that will invite her to the
screening she said yeah I'm down and
then my mom and emailed me this and said
oh I know how much you love Sleeping
Beauty's so I bought all of us ticket if
Lee is available he can come too so then
a week later I had forwarded this email
to be to Lee and said Oh fYI we have to
go see this movie with my family it's
like one of my favorites oh okay well if
I'm getting invited to my own proposal I
think I must be doing a pretty good
[Music]
there were a lot of logistics to be
managed the idea we had then was well
maybe it's we stick all the friends and
family we push them to the back and then
let's get some people that she doesn't
know to sort of fill those seats right
around her to kind of distract her from
the friends and family we put put this
on reddit you know said hey I'm looking
for I think I use the words I'm looking
for random Internet strangers to help
fill the theatres so I can surprise
propose to my girlfriend kids back
behind me were dressed up and I thought
they were cave you're sleeping beauty
and I was like oh god they're not gonna
be able to see Sleeping Beauty I don't
know like it happened and like it wasn't
like really making sense I just I think
I was like so many emotions we're going
through and like was really special
that's as good as it gets the best part
is I get to spend the rest of my life
with Lee which is always something that
really is what brings a smile to my face
to me one of the most mind-boggling
parts of all of this has been seeing
that not only have people in America
enjoyed watching this but across the
globe I think we all sort of suspect
deep down that everyone around us sort
of wants the same things we all
appreciate love we all appreciate
respects this kind of sounds super
cheesy but like we're not that different
like no matter where we are on the
planet the fact that this resonated so
widely really reaffirmed that belief
that I've always had
you